so now i'd like to invite uh
miss shrigori
krishnan
who krishna kumar she is going to help
us help the students go through this
entire experience of showing their
posters that could be evaluated over to
you
um shri gauri
all right thank you so much doctor
so far we had an exciting uh sessions
that talked about the various active
areas of research that are happening in
the field of bioinformatics and data
science in the academic industry in
india and we also discuss some of the
what are the various opportunities that
students can access and
where to access these opportunities and
how to access them keeping these in mind
there still remains one of the challenge
that students uh
face that is they don't get the
opportunity to showcase their project
after completion so that is why the
omics research symposium encourages
students worldwide to present their to
present their research project and
network with peers and experts in the
field
so
the topics of the symposium is omics and
bioinformatics ai machine learning and
data science astrobiology and spaceomics
computational biology in biotechnology
and pharmaceutical industry the
submission was open to all registered
participants from high school
undergraduate graduate as well as
citizen science projects and out of the
25 plus abstracts that we have received
we have selected 12 of the finest
projects for further rounds of review by
the judges now let me take a brief
moment to introduce you to the judges
who will be reviewing the student
projects
first we have mr dr ramesh kumar he is
the assistant professor
uh at brevard university we are also
joined by dr harpreet kaur she is the
post doctoral researcher at nci nih we
are also joined by dr agreed in lakshmi
narayan he is the research consultant at
pine biotech and dr abhishek sengupta is
the assistant professor at mit
university and finally and last but not
the least dr julia panel she is the
associate director at top of
bioinformatics research center australia
the presentation will be judged in four
categories that is introduction methods
and results discussion and conclusion
finally if the students are able to
showcase a quality driven project within
the timeline the best posters will be
selected on
on the following different categories
that is best technical research project
promising research direction for future
potential and most innovative approach
in an established domain
and the guidelines for the competition
are simple the participants will be
given five minutes to press in their
poster once the time is up you'll have
to stop your presentation and move to
the next candidate so kindly make sure
that you complete your presentation
within five minutes with that let me
invite the first
participant who will be presenting their
project that is doctor parikh sir she is
the professor at ranka college of
science and technology chatham india and
she and her team will be presenting her
project on characterization of the
hypothetical protein sequence of
nigleria fabulary using bioinformatics
approach
so over to you dr pratt
uh yeah ma'am am i audible
yes you're audible
i'll be
is my screen visible
yes it is visible
okay thank you so much
okay
uh
good evening to all the judges uh myself
doctor parekh sagan and i'm representing
roonda college of science and technology
delight and my colleague is pratikya das
research associated at the biotech uh we
have chosen a topic to work on
characterization of a hypothetical
protein sequence of neglect foliary
using a bioinformatics approach now this
particular amoeba is causing a disease
which is called as pam okay so pam is
primary amoebic meningocephalitis
this disease is basically cause when
somebody goes for swimming in the open
uh kind of water environment so this
particular amoeba is inhaled via nose
fills and this can cause lot of issues
and can be very infectious and can be
fatal for one person's life
so uh particularly when it is taken
inside another three uh lives in the
life cycle of uh nagera flori there are
three phases so one is cyst phase
another is tropozoid phase and and
there's a third one so in these three
phases uh the trophozoites are the most
severe one which causes the infection
because they can uh they can uh multiply
themselves with the binary fusion method
and uh they are uh they can cause that
much of infection infection that a
person can die in seven days okay so by
looking through this uh particular slide
we can see if cerebrospinal fluid the
diagnosis is cerebrospinal
uh from cerebrospinal fluid that gray to
yellow color is changed and uh when uh
one ml of blood sample is taken and it
is being checked so it is found that the
red blood cells number is very high so
person can be suffering from
this particular family disease there are
various type of treatments known for
this
so this is a life cycle we are i've
already told about cysts trophozoite and
flagellate phase
so we can see here the
division of the cis-2 trophozoite phase
and which is the infectious one
okay so in this particular project i
have tried to
find some details about the hypothetical
protein which is not available in the
database so i have tried to find all the
information about it using various
bioinformatics tools and there is
something new which i have discovered in
the project while uh doing the
calculations with the bioinformatics
rules about negala flow very which
causes this disease
so we can see the list of the
bioinformatics tools i have used i will
tell you what a new thing which i have
discovered when i was doing the project
so this is the approach i have used this
is the hypothetical protein and this is
the id number of n-flow vary that
particular protein which uh with about
which the information is very less
available in the databases its structure
is not there its detail is not there its
protein-protein interaction was not
available so by the approach i was able
to figure out about this so this n flow
vary this particular id was i have got
this from the uniprot database and i
have tried to perform the blastp by
which i was able to figure out the list
of 10 sequences uh similar to this
particular id and that was easily
available and they were around 82 of the
sequences but i took the first 10 to
understand what could be the maximum
similarity with its co similar uh kind
of species from the same family so the
first 10 sequences i have taken enflow
very five and the next thing which i
what i was was to tell you was that
there is another species called as n
gruberry okay so negala gruberry i have
taken five sequences of that and five of
uh flow vary just for the support of
study so after i generated the multiple
sequence alignment of these ten
sequences enclave and ngrubery i was
able to see the conservation of the
amino acid pattern in the sequences that
supported the data that they belong to
the same family and then i have tried to
discover the
kind of
family they belong to the same family
and there was some patterns common
patterns were seen in the pro site
database and uh something which was
different was in the string database
when i wanted to see about the protein
interaction i was not able to figure out
anything for n flow very but when i took
the next five sequences of n grew very i
was able to figure out some similarity
in the co-similar sequences of ngrubery
so this was something new which is not
yet reported so i figured out this and
after the structural characterization
when mod base i have used there was no
structure which was modeled for nfl very
and i was able to make it with the help
of swiss automated modeler the results
i'll be showing soon and more
information about this particular
sequence i have figured out an amoeba
database which shows that this
particular hypothetical protein is uh
very important uh in some kind of keg in
metasec pathways which i'll be showing
later so this is this is uh very much
important in doing some
metabolic activities
uh so we are going to the results
section from the uniprot this is the
idea i have uh retrieved for uh negala
flawberry and this was all about the
project where this was the main idea to
figure out the details of it these are
few sequences which i have taken for
enflowberry and gruberry together just
for the supportive steady
this is the multiple sequence alignment
so i can show you the conservation over
here the sequences are very highly
conserved among amongst these 10
sequences and
i was able to figure out from
the pfam and the cdd database that they
are all belonging to have the hsp70
domain so this confirms that it is also
having hsp 70 domain like rest of the
sequences
then
from this particular analysis of uh cdt
database it confirms that they are
belonging to the same clan
36495
they are having the same accession
number and the same super family ptz uh
four times zero nine
then from the interpro databases these
are few of uh the patterns uh from the
domains i was able to figure out ipr
numbers are given so i was able to
figure out that they are belonging to
the same family and clans
then i was able to figure out some
patterns which were similar so i can
show you a heat shock protein heat shock
hsp 70 patterns are present so they are
having around uh five sequences when n
flow variables they will run 15 hits i
have got from pro side this is the
string result so this tells that when i
have used inflow vary there was no
result and just to support my study i
have tried that if enflow very is not
there and gruberry can be present for
protein protein interaction which is
just similar and belongs to the same
family so i was able to see that there
are co-occurrences there are some
literature-based reports available uh
these are those id numbers which are
which i've shown you in the blast
results so they are having some or the
other relation between them
then using the cis model i was able to
figure out that uh with this template
number of 4a and i1 it was able to
generate based upon sequence identity
that the structure can be like this for
the hypothetical protein which is not
available in the database and very much
important it is based upon sequence
identity it means that uh it this model
has been generated based upon the place
of the amino acid so this is based upon
the sequence identity
okay so this is the last result where i
can show you the amoeba database has
shown that these are some of the
important pathways like it is involved
in the purine metabolism and thymine
metabolism
so overall conclusion of my project is
that whatever information was
available for enflow very was very less
to enterprise in india there are only
around 15 cases reported and with the
help of n group area data i was able to
support my studies that some information
can be said that uh gruberry and
flowberry are similar they belong to the
same family and the results can be
checked that way thank you so much
all right thank you so much thank you
mom
the judges already have any feedback to
give to dr parrik
uh i'll just uh show my poster as well
uh judges uh do you have any feedback to
give to dr parrik
about her project
uh yes hello um hello dr parrik
yes it was nice work so i have one
actually suggestions maybe when you're
choosing like 10 sequences
so
instead of choosing 10 sequences it
would be better if you use some criteria
like maybe percentage of similarity so
maybe 90 similarity of the sequences so
maybe that would be the better criteria
rather than just using the top ten
sequences
so because when we comparing some
sequence so we
should consider its similarity or
dissimilarity score so my suggestion is
fine for this work if you're just doing
for the publication perspective it would
be much better like if you consider that
yeah
uh rest of thing is fine like it is
interesting
okay okay bam thank you so much for the
suggestion um i'm just i would like to
say something uh because the idea behind
this project was not to figure out the
similarity uh initially it was just
about to figure out only the information
about the hypothetical protein so that
criteria i may have missed as per you
have said so but yes for the publication
point of view for the next i will
consider this thank you so much for the
suggestion
yes
all right thank you so much dr parrik uh
could you please stop sharing the screen
yes ma'am yes
thank you
all right uh so let me invite the next
participant uh
mr kashish kundu he is a postgraduate
student of bioinformatics and
computational biology from amity
university
and he will be presenting his project on
in silico analysis of transcriptional
responses to uv and ir radiations so
over to you kashish
thank you so much ma'am
[Music]
uh yes
so good evening everyone myself
and um about my
poster
in skin in skin cancer
many genes are involved in known dna
damage response pathways for cell
cycling and proliferation
and also in apoptosis their dna rep
repair or in stress other stress
responses
however majority of the
these genes are involved in unexpected
pathways with functions in
single in signal
transduction rna binding and editing
protein synthesis and degradation energy
metabolism and cell structure
i was interested in knowing these
responses hence i chose a particular
data set to work on
uh the analysis was uh on the data set
was done on tbi info server along with a
few other
tools and
platforms
this part of
poster represents the
wait a second
yeah so this was the introduction which
i gave about my poster
yes
so this part of the uh
poster represents a methodology that was
used along with the flowchart
illustrating the uh
the pi the pipeline that was followed
firstly the dataset was identified on
ncbi using geodataset database a
database was downloaded and filtered and
grouping of the sample was done so of
the samples was done
pca and other statistical analysis were
performed manually as well as using gui
platforms
later on uh
pathway analysis was done using links
tool and
panther db links database that is
library of integrated network based
cellular signatures takes up input as
gene ids fold change information and an
optional field for p values
protein analysis through evolutionary
relationships abbreviated as panther
it links protein sequence
evolution to the development of protein
activities and biological functions
separated files of genes are accepted as
inputs and as output graphical
representation of gene expression levels
are plotted against the pathways they
are expressed in
from here further biological
interpretation was made
from the top broadsides the ir
responsive genes
like atf3 map2 mef2c were involved in
stress response genes like pvt1 mmyc
nek2
were involved in cell cycle and
proliferation there were there were many
genes with involvement in signal
transduction and apoptosis
for uv responsive genes similar results
will come with entries in stress
responses
signal transduction
energy metabolism and apoptotic pathways
from the results recorded it can be
interpreted that
abrupt activities of cell cycle and
energy metabolism may cause ir as well
as uv induced skin lesions apoptotic
cycle
showed an increase in the expressions
which can be inferred as immune activity
to tackle the lesion development or it
can also indicate the breakdown of
essential cellular components that were
aided in prevention of further
proliferation of abnormal sins
the outcome proposes that
protein translation is
additionally
hindered by a halted transcription of
trna synthetase genes
now uh here you can see the pca result
which was uh
drawn out and this shows the panther db
result along with the bar charts of
the
genes that was uh
expressed now using panther db
these two two tables shows us the
threshold that i took that is the nine
gene uh from this table and i studied
these pathways
i haven't covered all these pathways
because instead of going into an
extensive research i was more
focused on the highly expressed genes
and
hence i went for these pathways
ah
sorry to interrupt you you have less
than 20 seconds now
okay yeah i'm concluding so
the conclusion section gives us a brief
of overview of the interpretations of
the analysis and the bar chart
represents the probes and information of
induced and
repressed genes of ir and uv
and for future perspective about this
project and now i'm looking into
the method comparison of
this data set that was
that i chose along with the method that
i used and
looking i am looking forward for its
validation now
thank you ma'am all right thank you so
much uh does the judges have any
feedback
for
kashish
[Music]
dr raghav dr harpreet
do you have any feedback
hello kashish
so um
i have uh just a few things so it would
be better if you just also show like how
many samples have you used maybe i
missed that so so that it is it should
be like statistically correct another
thing when you actually uh this is just
for the uh i mean from the analysis
perspective i'm not going into the
deeper science so another thing in your
principle uh pca results and your
pathway results so it would be better if
you maybe do it based on the sam uh
sample group because when you're drawing
this pc it is difficult to understand
like what is actually with which group
is there or which is not i i guess you
just assigned it you know
yeah ma'am uh actually i before i have
the result for both uh before grouping
the pca
how uh actually i was looking if there
is any similarity or any plot
interpretation which can i take
which may
which i may find without grouping the
data once it was grouped into ir uv and
separately for uv and ir uh i have
inferred that information also there
so it would be much better when you're
doing even in the first group before
grouping you can take actually
uh i mean you can color your sample
based on either this
radiation type because it's difficult to
interpret anything out of this like
whether these groups are dismisses from
each other or not so that's something
that you need to maybe
uh
must do this or reanalyze it uh so
because it is difficult to interpret at
the moment yeah okay okay
could you please stop sharing the screen
yes ma'am thank you ma'am
so
next i would like to invite uh
mr
emmanuel uh and team will be presenting
their project on visualization of the
chromosome one genomic data from the
african american asian and european
populations over to you
emmanuel uh are you there
all right then so let's move on to the
next participant uh miss anika ghosh she
will be presenting her
project on
transcriptomic analysis of hippocampal
subfield ca1 in alzheimer's disease
over to you anemica
hello all
uh
so i am sharing my screen
is it visible everyone
yes it is possible could you please zoom
in
thank you so much
yeah so i can easily zoom in here uh
okay so hello everyone so today i am
going to present my project topic
transcriptomic analysis of hippocampal 7
in alzheimer's disease so what is
alzheimer's disease alzheimer's disease
is a neurodegenerative disorder
or may affecting mainly the elder
population
uh
epithelial it could be observed in the
younger population
but its prevalence is more in the older
generation there are several hypotheses
that exist behind
this alzheimer's disease however the
some uh
some of like
not all of them are really uh
accomplished or really found enough
evidence so here is a comparison between
the healthy brain and and a brain that
is uh affected by severe alzheimer's
disease and here is another diagram that
shows uh hallmarks of alzheimer's
disease which include accumulation of
amyloid blood proteins neuroinflammation
mitochondrial dysfunction autophagy
autophagy dysfunction
and polarity insufficiency and uh
last but not least the neurofibrillary
tangles
so in our here is an overview of uh the
methodology of what we have uh done so
for the second project we have used the
this data set
from june's uh gene expression omnibus
the pre-processing of the dart data was
carried out with the help of microsoft
actual 2019
after processing of the data we have uh
quantum nominated our data and labeled
it
followed by this we have we run
principal component and analysis and we
uh detected x119 as an outlier and
removed it
and uh
then we ran dc2 and insert enrichment
analyzer
after uh determining statistically
significant genes say we validated our
results
uh results
so here is an overview of
like our results section so as we can
see here this is the result of the
principal component analysis
so the pc one it accounts for
223.01 percent pc2 accounts for 18
18.19
and pc3 accounts for
14.75 percent variance x119 as mentioned
earlier is detected as the earlier
is detected as uh the outline and we
have removed it and proceeded further so
here is a volcano plotted showing the
upregulated and down regulated ginseng
and
the right side shows the positive
approach of chicken and upregulation
ferrous and left side social negative
upregulation here is the gene ontology
analysis for our uh data sector so
activated and suppressed pathways are uh
separated by two separate boxes and
the gene count is reflected by the size
of this uh circles
[Music]
gene ratio is mentioned at the bottom of
the boxes
and here is the mention of the p
adjusted values
and there is this is the c net plot of
our genes and gene ontologies so uh both
these are the genes that are the full
change is negative so they are basically
down regulated and there are some gene
ontology terms again they are also down
regulated
here is the uh
yeah here is the result of our cage
enriched pathways analysis so here it we
can see again that activated and
suppressed uh
pathways are separated by two boxes gene
ratio is mentioned here in the bottom
and here is the uh like we can see the p
adjusted values the red uh signifies the
most significant ones of the statistical
significant ones
okay so next so for the sake of the
validation what we have did is uh
we uh took the gene list of the table uh
supplement supplementary table is 5 of
the main paper that is associated with
our data set and we compared it with our
results
uh the output file that we uh got after
uh digital analysis so we mainly uh
went for the uh statistically
significant uh
statistically significant ones so our
results saw sure that there is zero
percent there is no overlap between this
uh two
list of genes so therefore we concluded
that uh
therefore we concluded that uh that it
might be due to the fact our uh
uh our my our project is very much
focused on the hippocampus hippocampal
subtle ca1
whereas the main paper was uh
was taking into consideration
consideration other hippocampal
substances so uh that is what i can say
about the conclusion section and here is
of my references
and
last but not least is i would love to
acknowledge my research mentors mr dr
raghubandam lakshmi narendra and elia
brodsky said for helping me out to carry
out this research project i would also
love to uh thank all the uh members of
the pine biot thank you
all right thank you so much does the
judges have any feedback for animaker
yeah i can uh i can ask this time maybe
um
thank you very much for the presentation
and um just a few questions about your
presentation so you mentioned that there
was an outlier in your data set
and that you included it so um did you
try to find out and understand why it is
an outlier
did you go back to the data and
try to understand
why this sample is an outlier
maybe
some normalization was done differently
because the main paper as i understand
did not mention any outliers
correct
uh yeah the main paper
actually to be honest i uh back searched
about the sample uh it's 119 but i could
not find anything really significant to
tell actually
but that's
i could not find anything
okay yeah just uh
just you know just uh
remark that usually
an outlier is something that you should
probably go and really
dig in into and try to understand why it
is an outlier maybe the problem is not
with the sample but with the
analysis so maybe you know analyzing and
looking at the data a little bit
differently would yield
different results
so also uh you mentioned the down
regulated genes and up regulated genes
and
and the pathways and everything you
you know those graphs that you talked
about
uh what i'm uh kind of was a little
missing is uh your interpretation so is
it are those uh pathways or genes
mentioned in literature
have they been found in
in alzheimer's disease before you know
some some of your
input on you know on the interpretation
of the results
so that was a little bit missing for me
um
and also uh
yeah the last graph where you have the
venn diagram and you show that you have
nothing actually in common with the with
the main paper uh maybe i'm
maybe i didn't
you know i didn't have time to go into
the data set itself but
you probably took only part of the data
from this uh
big data set i i'm guessing
right
actually we have i have cons we have
considered the statistical significant
genes only that is p value of less than
0.05
so
it was mentioned in the supplementary
table s5 in the main paper that is the
last one and here is actually my 181
gems so i compared that
right so you so you said that none of
the genes actually uh were the same
uh so i was wondering probably they had
more samples and maybe did different
differentiation
or was it the same because if you had
nothing in common
that's a little
you know concerning i guess
that's
that's just uh interesting uh
actually i take it another in another
way uh like i
that paper the original paper uh the
what they did was related to all
hippocampus circles and also ec or
adrenal cortex but i when i did not find
any like overlapping gene
i uh went back to the data right the gse
file and where i what i found out that
the data
submitted in the geo or gene expression
omnibus
database that is very specific to
hippocrates a1 that i have mentioned so
i am very positive about my results
actually
because i think my result is specific
for ca one
okay no problem just i wanted to can i
can i interrupt uh actually i was
expecting anemica to tell this and the
comparison that she did was with the
differentially expressed proteome from
proteomics data analysis from different
regions of alzheimer's disease patients
so that's what the paper actually they
said and that's what she took to compare
her differentially exposed genes list
that she got from hippocampus
i was
yeah that's why we did not or she did
not find a lot of
common genes between the differentially
expressed proteins analysis from
proteomics data which i see
okay averaged out data from several
regions of alzheimer's disease patient
from one specific region that is
hippocampus that is differentially
exposed genes that she found out i i see
yeah and i think this is pretty much
known that uh there is little
actually a lot of times there is little
interaction between the proteomics and
the gene expression
so yeah this makes sense
thank you